patience in language learning is like
fishing
[Music]
hi there today i'm going to talk about
something i've mentioned before
patience in language learning
and i'm going to use a comparison sort
of like a metaphor
and i'm going to say that language
learning is like fishing now if you
enjoy my videos please subscribe
you can click on the bell to get
notifications
and of course i welcome you to come and
join me at link which is where i learn
languages
first of all if you look at my
statistics for the week i'm sort of
slowing down i'm creating fewer new
known words
uh probably won't reach my goal of 20
000 known words on the positive side
i've had three discussions recently with
mohammed in cairo and i just feel i'm
doing a lot better and you know it's
nice to i might step it up here again
but it's it's nice to have that feeling
that you're doing well
and
in the end it's how you feel about your
language that matters it doesn't matter
whether other people point out
inadequacies if you feel more
comfortable i feel more comfortable i
understand more i can say more i'm happy
and i will continue until the end of
november
one other thing
uh expolingua which normally happens in
berlin around this time of year a
language conference international
language conference mostly in german
their conference is going to be online
is a conference uh tile neyman andy's a
conference title
i'm link here in the
felt
so i'll leave a link to the conference
in the uh description box
and it's the 18th to the 21st of
november it's all online it's mostly in
german i look forward to seeing you
there and now let's get back to my main
discussion
so i was thinking about this this
morning
i like to study languages in the morning
i get a sense of pleasure just going
through text now in arabic seeing more
and more
on my ipad there's more and more white
words there's fewer and fewer new words
uh now that i can go through chunks of
the text listening to the
original audio
uh you know from these podcasts i i read
the english translation that google
provides and i listen to the arabic and
i can sort of follow connect the words
to what i'm reading then i go through
the text and i pick off you know the
words that i still don't know and some
of the words that are yellow that i've
looked at before but i've forgotten
and i enjoy doing this it's like fun and
i'm doing it early in the morning and it
reminded me of my friend who lives in
calgary
and uh the sort of during the fly
fishing season he likes to get up at
five in the morning and go
fishing on the bow river which flows
through calgary and which is meant to be
one of the best fly fishing
uh
rivers in the world
or so people in calgary like to say
but
you know it made me realize and of
course his fishing is catch and release
and and that's the nature of learning
words we learn a word and then we throw
it back
into the pile of words that we actually
still don't know
except in languages we end up eventually
keeping the fish whereas in fly fishing
they release the fish and catch another
fish
uh i don't particularly enjoy fishing
but
to be a fisherman you have to enjoy the
process of fishing
you can't be there saying tease like you
know why haven't i caught a fish i'm in
a hurry to catch a fish
it's the same when we learn languages we
can't be saying geez why am i not doing
better how quickly can i
you know learn this language so i can
speak it
we have to have this sense of enjoyment
patience
uh enjoy the process
and unlike and in fishing if you're not
fly fishing on the bow river the chances
are you are going to eventually catch
some fish i have been fishing i've been
fishing in you know on vancouver island
campbell river port alberni
uh out at 4 35 in the morning uh and
just watching all the birds and the
wildlife and the forests and not really
caring about whether i catch a fish or
not
i guess some of the keener fishermen are
very keen to catch fish i'm not
i've been on the slave lake
uh where there's lots of fish you just
put your line down you pull up a fish
pike or pickerel or whatever it is
but the thing about fishing is that it's
you know a
fishing is sort of universally popular
not that everyone likes fishing i'm not
a big fisherman but in every country of
the world people enjoy fishing
so it's a very popular thing to do
people enjoy it
because they can sit there by the stream
or you can travel you can go fishing in
argentina you can go fishing in japan
you can travel the world uh fishing so
again it makes it a bit like language
learning in that it brings us into
you know beautiful scenery different
countries
the same way language learning brings us
to interesting subject matter
enables us to discover new cultures
and if we enjoy the process
uh you will stay with it we'll want to
do it again
uh we'll gradually catch fish
uh
we may have to return some of the fish
but we'll eventually get some fish
we may eat that fish it's delicious it
can be delicious it can be prepared in
different ways
so uh you know i just thought of this
like sitting there this morning doing my
enjoying the process
i don't know how much
i'm progressing in my arabic in terms of
speaking i don't know that i speak much
better than it did before i will have
sort of an exit video here after my
90-day challenge in arabic and you can
judge probably don't speak much better
certainly understand much better
and i enjoy the process i'm not
impatient
and i think this is the attitude of a
good fisherman
patient
skilled good preparation you know making
sure they select
the right bait
so we have to find
the right bait the right
content things of interest to us so that
we get engaged with the language uh
fisherman wants the fish if the
fisherman doesn't want a fish
he's not going to catch any fish
similarly in language learning we have
to want to learn
but we we should really do it with
patience
and enjoy the process so there you have
it a bit of a
metaphorical discussion
comparing the joys of fishing
with the joys of language learning
i look forward to hearing your comments
bye
[Music]